the coronavirus is forcing meat
companies that feed our country to close
processing plants nearly 750 employees
are infected from the now shuttered
Smithfield plant in South Dakota and
yesterday a pork processing plant in
Minnesota shut down it's tied to at
least 33 cases there these facilities
are contributing to a spike in cases
across several Midwestern states and our
Adriana Diaz shows us how this is
affecting the whole industry coronavirus
cases in Iowa's Black Hawk County have
doubled in recent days to 356 and public
health officials say 90% trace back to
employees at this Tyson meatpacking
plant 132 thousand citizens of Black
Rock County are now the victims of the
apathy of the absence of protocol of the
lethargy in response from corporate
Tyson sheriff Tony Thompson toured the
plant earlier this month he says the
facility should close for deep cleaning
and better screen its employees the line
moves so quickly that they work elbow to
elbow
they have about a 36 inch workspace and
they're just stacked on top of each
other
Tyson says it since made changes
company-wide requiring employees to wear
face coverings and installing dividers
on production lines we've worked
diligently to protect our team members
by taking worker temperatures at the
start of each shift and identifying
symptomatic team members their outbreak
is not an isolated case CBS News has
confirmed Kovach cases in at least 17
meat processing plants in ten states 13
of which have temporarily closed or
operating at reduced capacity but the
closures come too late for some families
78 year old Sal Sanchez who worked at
the now-closed jbs meat packing plant in
Colorado died from coronavirus Agustin
Rodriguez an employee at the Smithfield
Foods pork processing plant in South
Dakota also succumbed to the virus
another Smithfield worker who's infected
and asked not to be named told us he
wasn't given a face mask until three
weeks after the plant's first case he
now fears for his
pregnant wife I just worry about my wife
and they my baby
despite the outbreaks the governor of
Iowa says studying down plants would
hurt farmers and the national food
supply chain we are the largest hog
producer in the country and it will be
devastating not only for the food supply
but for the cost of food going forward
Ben Lewiston who helps run the Institute
for agriculture and trade policy says
companies can reduce production to make
the plants safer for employees regularly
in the u.s. we produce way more than we
can consume nearly a third of u.s. pork
production is for export so we can slow
down our production protect our workers
make sure there's enough meat for us
consumers we reached out to Smithfield
Foods to find out when exactly they
started providing masks to their
employees but we haven't heard back now
both Iowa and South Dakota have not
issued state sanction stay at home
orders even though the operates of these
facilities are already impacting
communities we also want to know that
the CDC says that there's currently no
evidence that coronavirus can spread
through food Tony as so many of us work
from home a reminder that many jobs
cannot be done from your home made
Rihanna thank you very much